we say this I mean we have to take a
little bit of a longer term perspective
than just today because you do have
Treasuries being bit up in the yield on
the 10-year for instance at session lows
of two point one nine five seven percent
but it's been a bit surprising it has
been surprising that hasn't been more
exactly because so much bad news has
come out I mean let's be clear you've
got China's you know a trillion-dollar
stock market having a particularly
horrible a couple of weeks and the
government being unable to do anything
on top of Greece on top of what's going
on in Puerto Rico on top of less
exciting news about the US economy so
you know you are seeing yields come down
somewhat for the 10-year US Treasury but
they can't go down that far if you think
that the Fed is actually going to hike I
mean think about what happened going
back 2010-2011 the last time you had
these sort of eurozone crisis talks
heating up he saw the 10-year US
Treasury fall from you know
three-point-six percent down to almost
two percent and the same kind of move on
the german 10-year boon yield also going
down about 1.5 percentage point how can
you see that if you've got the ten-year
German booney land at point six percent
now I mean you cannot go maybe you can I
don't know to negative 1 percentage
happened before but buyers went on
strike in Germany when the bund yield
got too low and a lot of people are
saying the blood market once again is
setting the pace for global bond markets
Bob cinch over at apps Becca has just
put out a note on this Amer securities
saying that the bun market is setting
the pace the question is where is the
safe haven that if you're not finding it
necessarily in the Treasury market in
German bunds is cash the ultimate safe
haven right now this is a phenomenal
question that a lot of people are asking
since so many central banks have engaged
in unprecedented stimulus programs
through the bond markets and sent yields
to such low levels there has become even
growing amount of volatility during
times of stress because these bonds are
not providing the same kind of haven
there isn't the same kind of room for
yields to go down that there once was
and if there is any sign of growth or
any sign of recovery those yields are
going to bounce right back because we're
nearing the point where you're not
getting a real rate of return on these
bonds if the economy is continuing to
accelerate you are seeing Swiss yields
today flirt with negative territory
again the nine-year yield and the
10-year yield there that is probably
because people are expecting a possible
recession in Switzerland because of the
strength think Frank and because of some
other circumstances unless you think the
same thing is going to happen in Germany
and the u.s. it doesn't make the same
kind of sense